eu acho que todos aqui presentes já
sonharam com o mundo onde robôs faziam
parte do nosso dia a dia
o mundo onde a realidade
finalmente encontra ficção científica eu
estou aqui hoje para lhes dizer que esse
mundo já começou
no filme de volta para o futuro eles
sonharam com o mundo onde fazemos
contato por vídeo conferência e tvs
flutuantes eram nossas atendentes bom
eles não estava tão errado assim robôs
tocam profundamente nos seres humanos
hoje nós estamos orgulhosos de dizer que
estamos promovendo o primeiro contato
com o robô de verdade para muitas
pessoas e isso ficará em suas mentes
pelo resto de suas vidas
os robôs estarão presentes em todas as
áreas de nosso dia a dia
eles mudaram completamente a forma como
interagimos e executamos nossas
atividades
o maior foi o que eu tô gravando um
vídeo aqui com ele um pouquinho que eu
tenho minha marca
tá bom obrigado mesmo o ano de andre
playboy te topless
eu sou bons modificaram completamente a
nossa economia
pense bem só podem fazer para o mercado
muito mais do que os tablets fizeram
quando você de computador
há pouco tempo atrás de acordo com a
mackenzie global institute robôs ter um
potencial de mercado de 1 com 7 a 4 com
5 trilhões de dólares em 2025 e isto
começa a crescer agora
hoje eu sou orgulhoso de dizer que o r 1
é o primeiro robô de telepresença da
américa latina e o melhor robô mundial
para aplicação na área da saúde onde ele
trabalha efetivamente há basicamente
dois anos
um dia vocês provavelmente serão
atendidos por 111 werre um t1 possui a
maior autonomia de utilização de roupa
mundial
são 24 horas e operacionalização sendo
que nós já possuímos soluções para até
dez dias
ainda existe toda a conspiração da
skynet de que os robôs irão dominar o
mundo e tentar distinguir toda a raça
humana
mas uma coisa é fato
antes de se revelarem eles serão nossos
melhores amigos
eu acredito no mundo
onde os robôs estão presentes em todas
as áreas do nosso dia a dia
por isso eu fundei a progic robert
aumann em uma divisão de nosso grupo com
a missão de transformar o brasil
referência mundial em tecnologia
robótica e inovação
nós da própria obra
acreditamos que roubou são sobre pessoas
a forma que desenvolver robôs é o
fazendo dos mesmos super interativas
como design simpatizante e com sou uma
fã grande facilidade de uso dessa forma
as pessoas podem criar uma conexão com
nossos robôs
essa foi a primeira cirurgia mundial
realizada com equipamentos hospitalares
conectados um robô de telepresença
foram três câmeras simultâneas em full
hd e ouvir a transmissão em tempo real
tudo isso conectado unicamente à rtp1
sem a necessidade de nenhuma fonte
auxiliar de energia
todo o procedimento cirúrgico demorou
cerca de oito horas de de
operacionalização e eu aí entrou o dano
e saiu andando da da sala de cirurgia
o avião tem um pode ser conectado é de
qualquer lugar do mundo através de
qualquer dispositivo conectado à
internet ou até mesmo sem a internet
através de um simples controle de xbox
através de uma série de sensores
dispositivos e câmeras
hoje não tem um consegue criar uma
imagem tridimensional em seu software
dessa forma mesmo que alguém pule na
frente dele ele não irá acredita
o rio tem um poço também reconhecimento
facial automático
assim quando eu paro na frente dele ele
sabe quem sou eu e ele estava todo o
sistema automaticamente ele possui
também reconhecimento de emoções
então ele é capaz de identificar
do eu estou feliz ou até mesmo quando eu
estou brava ou ele sabe se eu estou
prestando atenção nele ou não
ontem 1 também roubou mais estável de
sua categoria
se você quiser derrubá lo é preciso
passar dessa inclinação à área da
medicina é onde encontra suas principais
aplicações consulta entre médicos e
pacientes em monitoramento da uti e
auxiliar de fisioterapia participação em
cirurgia toda a área da telemedicina
toda a área de humanização com as
crianças são apenas algumas de de alguns
exemplos do seu vasto campo de
operacionalização
o r1 pode ser conectado também ao os
equipamentos hospitalares microscópios
estetoscópios câmeras de pele o que
vocês quiserem
ele é capaz também de se conectar aos
softwares hospitalares sistemas de
gestão prontuário eletrônico e até mesmo
todo o sistema de imagenologia pode
estar disponível atrás de nós temos aqui
uma ressonância real de um paciente
eu posso trocar os contrastes para
conseguir chegar mais facilmente
essa é a região afetada ele tem um tumor
no cérebro
eu posso inclusive mexer uma imagem 3d
três dimensões que me facilita a
operacionalização a região afetada
é possível inclusive selecionar
determinada área e mandar imprimir uma
impressora 3d
o controle de infecção hospitalar também
não passou despercebido é a laser e
câmeras de desinfecção podem ser
facilmente acoplados ao rio ontem 11 ele
possui também uma pintura especial anti
bactericida e hidrorrepelente que o
deixa basicamente a prova de micróbios
facilita sua higienização eo deixa
praticamente à prova d'água
nós acreditamos também e desempenhar um
papel ativo na diminuição do
distanciamento social de pessoas com
deficiências
o r1 ele possui um sistema de controle
exclusivamente através dos olhos e sendo
ideal para tratamentos com esclerose
símbolo de hatch ou o que estejam em
recuperação após a um treinamento na uti
esse software ideal eu vou demonstrar
ele aqui pra vocês eu vou precisar vou
utilizar o teclado apenas pra dar um
clique do mouse para ser mais fácil
o idec chile se num e e sabe como a
melhor parte de tudo isso é que tudo que
vem que vimos até aqui é apenas uma
pequena parte do que está por vir
imagine as possibilidades no final
desafiar o status quo e trazer inovações
têm sido uma constante em minha vida eu
queria convidar a todos a enviar suas
idéias e sugestões para o site da
project
afinal robôs ainda não têm ideias apenas
os humanos têm meu muito obrigado